as part of our bundesliga trilogy
with uli hoeneß here and volker
struth the player consultant can also
be heard on youtube here in the podcast and
holds the hans joachim watzke business
from borussia dortmund of course also
very, very many years in the
football business who has also lived
on the ground again  was almost broke as a company
was now listed on the stock
exchange is worth over a billion was
now a little less of
the wisdom extremely good like marketing
and sport and show business and also the
future of the whole thing somehow maybe
going out will also be an
entrepreneur yourself very exciting
started  own company which i think
would have gone very well would have stayed with
it but he didn’t do it as a
cellist borussia dortmund what’s up
with his own
voice the first questions come up right away and then
the really great borussia dortmund
story from the ground up to the sky  and
now again somewhere on de  n second
place back now straight into the
conversation with hans joachim watzke
warm welcome has made itself warmly
welcome
actually
you are not a born
sports company in that sense it was
no coincidence yes that was basically
sport or let’s say
football more precisely  Yes, my life
has been shaped like nothing else. It's
clear that I actually got the
ball off
my feet at the age of two or three. I've been involved
with football my whole life, but of
course even if you
see the amateur leagues at some point, that's for the
top  not enough and so that hints
also give you a second chance and
yes, that's what I did then, I did,
I studied, back
then it was something different than it is today, where
everyone studies, back then it was
a bit higher, something extraordinary
you could do in the place  where i come from and 1000
souls village where i was born
erling from and is popular then
i  At some point I was moved to Marsberg,
so in a reorganization phase, but back then it
was still the absolute
exception and my parents
saved it from their mouths
and in that respect it was a
privilege for me too, yes, and then
I quickly studied because I had no
money  and I also wanted to have money
and when I was almost 25 I
started as an employee
in a company that also
produced fire-fighting clothing and protective clothing and
didn’t remain loyal to the industry as usual.
I then set up my own business after five and a half years
because I
just noticed it  so i was already
relatively in the hierarchy i had
moved up quickly but i was
on two and on 1 it was without the
head of the company it was namely the 1 and
his children when at some
point followed that they came to 1 world and
i thought that's it  not his world
and so I decided to do the
complete cut again  what
was not so easy for my parents back then,
especially for my mother, who
also had a bit of a need for security,
because I then when I started my
own business, we
were the industry leader at the time, my
company where I was and
the boss at the time obviously had that too
sworn eternal
enmity then eventually broke it up after 25 years
but not earlier and then
i paid because of salary so i started my
own business at the age of 30
that wasn’t even half
of what i had earned before and
that and that’s what counts  once again nice well
that was that was already those were
real real ruptures yes and
then I have that 15 years I have managed the
company 99 was founded 90 as
I said in april I was just before 31
june I won 31 that did 15
years  and then the vw only came along
in this existential crisis, otherwise
i wouldn't have gotten this chance, but i would  da silva text is called
having founded the company has been making sales
in the range of 15
to 20 million for several years now, you can
understand that
i have of course
researched this and am preparing that
at the same time he is the
industry leader in the segment so
engelbert strauss will be  the fact that he's the
world market leader in workwear i think he's grown from 100
million in sales to a billion
doesn't get annoyed and you
almost think to yourself that
i would have had a chance if i had
stuck with it back then the watt is full-time
to make also to build a thing what
now like  yes definitely was that the
decision was where i left
then of course i had the company
that was also
a hard time for the company now it's ok now it's
going to be a different time because
now my son has been with us for two and a half years and he
does that  you can
already see that every father is
somehow a bisc  hen more precisely
to glorify his children a bit but
he gets that in his blood without any glorification worth it
and i see what is happening
right now my wife has handled it super
from the anatolian from the
structural from the financial side
but i'm never
i always want to  still less than a percentage of
society but we didn’t take any
risks we simply had our market,
the niche market we
continued to work on it and had very
good figures every year, above all, of course
, sometimes we know that it is profit-oriented but
not growth-oriented, but now there is
a phase in the company that
I notice  but that it would be strong now
I'll do it I have to do that
my son in combination with my
wife who also creates the facts and also manages the
files and so and you so
next to it with his
his sales skills does that better
than I ever have  made but annoys
you anyway you are these two
decades  almost
donated or dedicated this now dortmund if you
would have used it that would have been a really
big thing you are the company that
belongs to a social one 100 percent yourself
and then maybe it will be a lot
bigger i have all that is that’s honest
it was never mine  topic my topic
was simply i wanted the company
to run in such a way that
the family could make a living from it that
the employees were paid
properly young people got money and that
was once my aspiration of course
i would certainly be twice as big
or three times as big today but  bvb was
for me at the end of the day a much
greater chance at the end not even
financially it doesn't find a life
than financial because
i wouldn't do a podcast if i
tripled the sales at becks otto didn't
go to bvb who recognizes that
however, that's not entirely
wrong, so white wasn't a
life decision, you have to
say that  my job was only
to save the club from insolvency in february 2015
that was the job where i
was given it was a
soft plan in that respect then he had plans because the
people who appointed me at the
time said at the same time we
won't do it  so the
confidence wasn't really there and i
felt it too i came
to the creditors' meeting on tuesdays and fridays and when you step, so to speak, four creditors
you can't offer anything
hate anything more than that was and what was your
person so what you are  the one two set
screws that can still be saved back
then I had to be honest
I was incredibly lucky too
that's just the way it is you start there
200 million debts 100 of them are
due and don't offer anything that
was the first block 2 is for  these
offer so the creditors just
thought of my sour the dialect
familiar okay he has closed in his
life up to now  at least distinguished by the fact
that he paid his bills
but didn't make any
promises that you can't keep
but honestly they had
no alternative the problem was
after the acute insolvency scenario was
then interrupted for the first time although
still not the same debts
still has nothing then  i was
extremely lucky that i
never met patrick jänsch in my
life completely by accident because of a completely
different story he
didn't really want bvb in front of me but vaud
visits me here at bvb as a
pattex partner because
they had one in southern germany  company
taken over as morgan stanley as a locust,
as they said back then,
they had taken over a company from the
insolvency
estate and years ago they had been a very large supplier to
my company and
they just wanted to see if I was
willing
to give them another chance  and again with
Working together with the company is
already done with them, millions
in sales per year and so I
listened to it Wittlich and olli Sweep away
when did we say I said something to
me if we can
certainly talk about it but have a look
bvb to see if  that thing has the dimensions 14
days so then said well
congratulations for your courage
but the thing that will never fly again
and then you said but again
if you somehow manage in the next six months
20 million additional
revenues every year
generate
then we can talk again
and we managed that somehow
we then did signal iduna stadium
which was highly emotional but was not
possible otherwise at that moment so in the
stadium sold
stadium names sold the legal office stadium sold the naming rights
then evonik we got involved
and then it somehow
fit and then they also went
ford  old and the decisive thing was
that patrick wanted
she lived in london back then that's the
moment morgan stanley man he was
the head of europe for recruiting
and and that was the achievement, if you like,
that i then in a year and a half
i flew to london almost every other week
and then this was
more successful in receiving the full football
what role
the floor played in rome back then that's also
sometimes because no one is with me to
appear so shortly after that he is
but he will  yes also always on 1 2 as a
guest who already claims
to have helped a bit with the
rescue yes that is not true but
that doesn't matter either
i have no problem with him because we
had no points of contact i spoke to you
once
those were and in this whole process
with morgan stanley and the like he
was no longer involved at all he was at the
same time his
personal din  ge da fechten
sold something so he was
n't actively involved in the election but you can,
as always, in the end we'll come back
to it that uli hoeness then also says
yes, I also helped at some point
and it's always the same
about it  he
brought him to bvb in 2003 or maybe never warmly and
then he had already
subscribed to a capital increase when he
says if he now if you
want to derive the analogy if he
hadn’t done it back then because they
had gone bankrupt earlier  then
maybe he really went broke
then that's certainly right but
at the end of the day i had relatively
little to do with him if you
look at the current almost insolvency cases
like how barcelona and something like that is
comparable
it's difficult to compare because
barcelona naturally has a
strong brand
we're always talking about february 2005 now,
we haven't been in the european cup for years
, we had one too  no longer a
good team there were still three
four players there knew this next
way now he sold it immediately to the
creditors went on
the stadium was sold there was
nothing left that means
Barcelona have accumulated exorbitant debts
but there is still mark
value, on the other hand, you have to say that and
i think that the situation of
borussia dortmund in february 2005 was
much worse than that of barcelona,
ally since what is still worth it even now after
kroner 56 78 100 million in sales
we made 75 million in sales
back then you were in  75 million
annual sales and 200 million
guilt you have to imagine
what happened then in the years to come the
drivers and to get forward well
at the end of the day after morgan
stanley had then agreed to
extensive restructuring they
then of course did  all creditors from
used goods huge problem and have
a capital increase wi
r morgan stanley made a third of the
shares and was our only
lender with such a huge sum
, of course, many in the
creditor advisory board but also in the
committees of bvb
said at the time that can’t do it
you can’t completely rely on new
frightened that  was a big
topic and i'm
still grateful for work to this day who also
supported me because i just
i wasn't naïve also knew that
the high risk is with morgan
stanley but i just believed in the patch
i knew he
don't let me know what the remaining risk is that i took on
is if he's gone at some point
it would have been
difficult but we
were lucky twice back then then there were
2008 there were 28 29 ties this
financial crisis he has the harvest in the morning
came under water that you sold
all your shares for 80 cents and what
do I know our bvb fans stocked up
on it  t
i was rid of the scene in the morning and
i get jürgen klopp first was basically
the game changer so you have to
say jürgen klopp or have years that
you must be lucky too if this
financial crisis this financial crisis was
perfect for us
because i got a break from it  once i suddenly
creep my biggest shareholder next to
who was certainly not only
characterized by idealistic motives because
right away it never
counted and that was and the people who
are supposed to have the shares they got it
too because we were
now that it's at penny stock level
the bvb fans have
stocked up suddenly there's a huge spread
in there yes and then jürgen klopp
we didn't have him from real madrid or
barcelona coach from mainz 05 after they
just didn't get promoted and the danish
had witnessed victory  Seen and
enthusiastic fit I would do it
like we weren't the
most beautiful bride at the time, you have to be fair  wise
say and that just fits together
advertise
michael zorc and didn't
identify him relatively early on the
only problem was that jürgen promised the mainzers yes
if he climbed up with him
it's still a yes and that's
why we naturally had a
huge problem for months and that just got better  decided on the
last day of the game that he
didn't get promoted yes and then where
jürgen probably came along
but not everyone said 2008 in
dortmund my god now it's
only going up but there were also
many people who said sorry and
second division at some point  became
autumn champion with mainz because we didn’t get promoted
so because the big hallelujah
that didn’t come until later,
as is always the case, we’ve just
talked about it if it works afterwards
then of course the success has
millions of fathers and nowadays everyone pretty much
already knew  have day where
he has been committed that is now
a big business  I think I
'd rather be in Hamburg, there
's a legend that he could have
started there, or maybe
even wanted to, but then he wore the wrong pants for the
interview, but
I don't think it was just about the
pants, but at least he did  who
obviously didn’t assess the chance correctly at the time,
now a trainer in general, the
decisive figure for the club in the
short term, that’s the most important
personal
thing, but if the trainer is
the most important
man in the club in the long term, then you already know
that at some point there will be a big problem
in the club  and we've seen
that often,
for example where otto rehhagel left
, but even more powerfully where
caught went, the
club hasn't recovered from
that for ten years because in the end that shouldn't be his
trainer shouldn't be the
most important man in the long term because you  you always have to have
your plan for the time
we no trainer, no matter how good,
manages today after 15 or 20 years
it is not possible and and of
course the trainer that is also his
job the trainer
always has to see from his position that he
gets maximum success in the short
term and in the end for it  do
n't look at it again the
opportunity costs are but he has to do
his thing and you have to as the
head of the club and the sports director is
certainly in between you have to
see him too but the long-term love
and every coach in the world
who would demand of me today that
we  go into
debt for a long time so that
we can achieve short-term sporting success, then i would simply
say that he is so strong now and you
as a character are weak then
something like that will happen and then when it happens and
at some point the trainer will be gone and then
you stand with him  the rest of the shards
what is what is such a
realistic trainer durability in
hard to say nowadays but you can see
that the times are going
further down so i would say today
that today one 10 12 years that
might still be just as possible in the biotope as
mainz ddp freiburg but with big
clubs i would follow me  that
would actually be nice if it were like that,
but it doesn't work anymore because the
demands on the trainer for us
make you wonder why you suddenly
go to bayern and pay so much money
for a daughter's trainer
probably only lasts for a short time and
then too  like a transfer fee paid and
i don't ask that from
bavaria my job me the problems or not
problems from is more like
bayern we didn't have any problems
i made it now because nagelsmann
is top and
and if you say short term is
the trainer  so important because this is also
paid the other question is whether you as the
releasing club does the
[music]
let me say nothing is because it is
to him  waiting for the trainers to
replace salaries and trainers and to
keep turning so would also have
to say there with two, let's see depending on what
happened last year,
you might have to 10 20 a.m. the
5 he represented we already have
yes there is no ban on thinking
but one thing is of course clear
the
transfer value of a coach is
something different than a setter and
you just have to do
that so that if if if a club that is
not healthy like bayern munich besides
the opinion is you can  so much to
pay and there are also many
arguments for then sometimes it's still
why not you always have to look at each individual
case but i wouldn't say
we're willing to
pay you so only this one depends on the
trainers it depends on the situation
it depends on his financial situation
but
[music]
that good trainers have always been important
is nothing new  orders made to
the tears
i want the top three jobs in his
club the top seeded must
include players and club what i
assume business of the store
is not completely irrelevant
then so i think now for
example thats good because i just do that
still has in the back of his mind is ajax
amsterdam there is edwin van der saar he is chairman of the
board
with whom we are not also on the board at
ecm then the top measure he is
sports director under the guest trainer i
think that those are the three
most influential figures of ajax amsterdam
are and obviously they do it
very, very well and that's so
clear and the players that's
another another level that's
not a level of responsibility the players
play for themselves at the end of the day and
they don't play strategically and
in perspective and what do I know
how the others work together we
have to plan the next one today
yes now  t again the next season
no player is currently thinking
about the next season
once again there was no
market value and
precarious situation spoken
look at the missing market will the
share and think man now I am
somehow worth significantly less than
than  menus i would even
say the degree fell apart far too
big dortmund and male
athleticism nevertheless
the somehow worth 2.6 billion job
and current market value are how good that
comes now also current knowledge through
the capital increase and honestly because of that
the roof was not underestimated
we  we now have a business model again for a short time
what for ford meyer
small business piccola the partying and
financial destruction process we did
the ghost games so that if
not finally smear but not
because he could earn money the
money was not made by him at the
moment i think  the big u  the difference
is and that we shouldn't
underestimate that
the big difference is that everyone knows
if you put enough money in
your hands then you can woo manchester united
that means if in the earth and then you're
there
it's not the 1  1
not what used to be for us and because borussia
dortmund is governed by the verwaltungs-
gmbh and i am as
if this verwaltungs-gmbh i
am ultimately an employee of the
club that shouldn’t be underestimated
most people don’t understand that but
that means that the  the shareholder or
the supervisory board does not even have
access to the top staff
and that is of course the case with manchester
united at all other clubs before there is
just 50 plus 1 or where there is
just another company zurück zur
sonne rein ag itself  bayern
munich is the chairman of the board
can the supervisory board
dismiss him immediately in our case it is not the
supervisory board we have  r now the organ
of the association is already a big
difference the capital market but we
have always communicated this openly and transparently
but as far as price drivers are concerned it
is already so
there will
not be a takeover battle oversized because at the end of the day
you can also have 70 or 80
percent here  the shares still
don't reverse the basic club policy,
so my colleague Windhaus, for
example, also bought from Hertha in
the clear assumption, I think, that 50
plus 1 hasn't been around for that long
and quite a lot of people say that, but
they doubt that where I've got it, at least
it's possible  also not the impression that well
i don't know that he i do
n't know but knew that he has relatively
little access to hertha bsc by
now will certainly know that
but can you work your thesis 50 plus
one over the next 20 years down
to the last cartridge  fighting for 50 plus one
because 50 plus 1 is not
about the scaffolding of investors
or similar  what do I know 50 plus one is a
bigger topic 50 plus one is a
topic for munich who love football and
what happens when 50 plus 1 is
abolished germany is
flooded with investors there may
be two three good ones but
who now believes in the  example that
the big US investor billions
then grabbed any
club from the second division
that was in danger of relegation and then all that
nonsense at the end of the day will be 4 56
objects and sees the league pays the
total price ruby england the prices would
triple in ticketing segni merch
ndising  everything is who in principle
this model to make the tickets too expensive
that the average earner can
no longer come to the stadium but
so that he because he still wants to enjoy football somewhere in
germany above all the england
also wants to bet at the same time
a subscription  buy this model is too
cynical for me that's clear what works  t
that's inexplicable why in england 14
million have subscriptions and
yes and in germany 500 or what and
it works and the entrance fees
are two to three times as high but that
's the price you pay the major
if you give up 50 plus 1 of
the  other prizes so that you
suddenly find
out what happens to a club in
saudi arabia i am i know of course there
are a whole lot of fans the songs
don't matter so this slip of the
tongue lukas newcastle i found the most
frightening yes what's up with me
human rights in saudi arabia are the
main thing now and it may
be that at some point that
will change with our society
i will always take a
different position because i want
football in germany to
remain affordable and
something is open to all sections of the population  yes somehow it is
also not strange to the investors
that they want the stadiums full
si  nd at least never say so i mean
the rising ones you always get success
the people with problems and higher question
is yes the only question is which people
are in it and i say it's
not about filling the stadium
england the stadiums are full but me
say whole
sections of the population will no longer be able to get in and if we in
germany football has always been an
issue for all sections of the population
and that is also one of the very few
glue for this
society we will certainly
completely agree that our
society is drifting apart in a brutal way
et cetera pp but because they didn't have any
common themes before, e.g. before
40 50 the churches still had a
binding force that's over dates the
associations binding force that's more or
less over political
parties the number of
members in the political
parties will also matter less  but football has this
connecting kr  still but if we of
course decouple 50 or 60 percent of the
shareholders from then
that will also be dropped and that's for me the
price is too high
then I think the English should
win the champions league three times more in ten years
that's
when the price is okay then then
you pay the price but for the fact that
we all still have the
opportunity in germany we can
be sold out again at 28 standing places for 14 euros that's
more important to me than that
we somehow get aramco or  whoever
here finds it totally the
same way i see the vision and the task of football on
the one hand my concern now would be
that while you mean the
right thing and act like that you will still
end up being left behind by the premier league
and that you will then  almost as a
punishment because you
have a half-empty stadium because the
fans say and the young fans say well
I have there and  certainly not if you
don't want to see all the
top premier league coaches who play top everything now
, then you actually
wanted to get an adhesive and the
big one wanted to get a structure,
which then breaks away anyway because
he's going to england for the attention
goes and when does your hand and tuchel
and klopp want to see and all of these
speak for it
on the other hand i
don't really see it we
just have to in germany bayern
munich can do it bayern munich can
do it with its economic  power and
also due to the fact of
course that is firstly done have been
doing for 50 years secondly that you
actually live in the bacon belt of the republic
you can keep up stadium
bavaria are always full here the
stadiums will be full later and the best
counterexample to your argument
is nevertheless  that the great majority in
Germany was against the Super League,
e.g  for example because the super league
was basically that was yes then you could
have taken a step forward as where it was dortmund really
to
be able to get involved with the really
big ones but
the vast majority of the Germans were
still against it and that shows me that
the mainstream is still like that when
at some point 80 percent of
the new generation say we do
n't want 50 plus one anymore we do
n't want a bundesliga either just want to
see big football but then it
won't be limited to the premier
league  then there will be the super
league of that i am convinced and
i want that
and then we and
bayern played a very big role i think i will
advertise it prevented if
we had taken part then you admit it today
i am convinced
and because we will  as before, are the largest
market in europe, but if
at some point everyone says that's the
that's the future well off then
i'm in the running  n is also clearly lost,
at least in the case of bavaria, one could have
the suspicion that this is also a
bit out of social desirability in
germany now not publicly your
interest or the
chance they didn’t see in the form
but i mean uli’s wish
hoeneß having to go to the super league
has been around for ten fifteen years, the thoughts have been around
and if you look now
i would almost at all from an
economic point of view he's
actually right you look at them right
now holland and belgium are going
it out as a league together  out of
necessity here almost irrelevant in spain
i would say why want to have the super
league i want is that so that
mr perez understands madrid very
clearly if i don't get
it i will be left behind here because
the spanish league is simply left behind
there  I also repaired no
chance of staying tuned and
that the forces are, so to speak, they
already are  have discovered that you do
n't have to go there and still and you are in
germany, it's right to
say yes, maybe that's not wrong,
but let's put it this way
, we have to state once again that
we still have the largest economy
in europe there should be  just
dare this national economy to demonstrate that,
too, one example is Braun, in addition
, the 40 largest companies in Germany would simply have to
merge umpteen times and say we
now offer the premier league for
overriding reasons,
sometimes behave against it because we will be
seven billion in
all sorts of things in this society  areas of
the pon but no one recognizes the danger if
germany soccer germany has
soccer in our DNA and if we
someday have soccer through two
plastic then that also has a
bit to do with why why do americans have to
why russians why arabs
why can't we yes that is  but
the forest and honestly  but that
's not the crucial issue either, that
you then want to live like that, that you
want to rest a club completely thanks, but
that you, as a large company in
Germany, now say we're going to support
the Bundesliga on a broad front,
i think that's a conceivable option  approach
because we don't have to hide and
to be honest we were just
talking about ireland first of all i had
neither on the field nor in the surrounding area
i had the feeling that the dutch
can enjoy football just because the
premium that the dutch league
certainly doesn't  the champions league will
win but i don't have that
atmosphere in amsterdam i've rarely
experienced such an atmosphere in a stadium so that's not possible either and
everyone from ajax will
know we wo
n't win the champions league this year so
but for that  is dutch football
nevertheless again and again they always manage it
with creativity has n
to come in again, that must also be
our approach, that we have
to discover bellingham and the saviour
, also accept that
we might be gone again at some point
, but maybe some people in
Germany will have the idea at some point,
that's
not it  the only thing that matters now is the question of the
future in the direction of ecology
, which is in the other areas
, but that the question of the future
of german football will also be in the
executive floors and the company will
move in and you say how important
this society actually is to us what
you say  hertener courageous replaced the child
quite well yes yes he is
one of those who
obviously sees it
that way we have yes he could
not invest all of a sudden
but he could at least
say again invested significantly more
is not about him
individual entrepreneurs who sponsor the individual
clubs but I'm e  It's
just that you maybe
pull the big companies together,
that they just invest in the Bundesliga
and
then everyone benefits via the distribution mode
, that would be a
measure to keep 50 plus one, for example, if
you want that, but I do  I
don't have the impression
at the moment that there are a lot of important
business leaders in Germany
who are thinking about it, so I
'd like to think they can
probably do it in a similar way
stock corporations
and you have we already have the
appropriate button that you could do
that you just
obviously haven’t fully
recognized the problem and the Americans are of
course further along and the Americans
that they’re naturally going for the premier
league is perfectly clear because
first was he has already
attractive
basic conditions  n you can, of course
, if you are not a grandmother,
let them do whatever you want, more or
less, unless they then
try to introduce the super league and the
language barrier that
we Germans have, but that’s
because the German economy needs to
knows a little bit more
where it will radiate again but you
can probably turn that off and
adjust the media to the fact
that the premier league will be a bit more of a
role for you your nba
as a and the federal league is then
not quite the bbl so not  the
basketball bundesliga but not
the npd is too bold for me because i've been
following football
relatively intensively for 55 years now and the only
thing that has become a determinant over
time is that
the conditions will change in
the ten to 15 years  90s everyone said the
series a is unbeatable for decades the measure of all
things ten years ago
everyone said the spaniards will
always be dominant no other
country has such result machines messi
ronaldo play in spain now
never play anywhere else
it's just my concern that can change
very quickly it
can also happen at some point it
was now  especially with the topic of the super
league I noticed that the english fans
at the end of the day don't
let themselves be anaesthetized forever and then,
but maybe also notice how
little they have to say at all,
how little influence they still have on what
happens once there  got
together a bit and
suddenly things went well thought that it is
possible so if you
pay the appropriate pressure then
a lot is still possible but the pressure is
simply by standing out they
feel it is not there the host but one
hundred percent again  come when
you suddenly realize what's
actually going on in our clubs
and we are still allowed to add ourselves to the
list that will also be
supporters and that's not my approach i
think democracy is exhausting but it
's always better than
other
forms of reference to our partner an ex cia nt
xp an dexia europe's answer
may be to  microsoft and amazon
aws a cloud computing company
founded by a 34-year-old
named alexander windbichler is based in
klagenfurt very impressive
story next year
a company will be part of it called net/kap and
here is a podcast special
net/kap ist mass  hoster also offers
webhosting domains virtual server and
has a podcast special offer
so can redeem a 20 euro voucher
with commercial 20 21 via
netcar.de so it almost doesn't matter how hosting
provider thinks in the area then
net/kap then maybe take the best
with you  and next year itself
is second message here
seek help above all things  40 vacancies
, above all in the
development area of offices worldwide from klage
furt to vienna cologne to new york
f course possible in the home office so if
you are looking for a job just check
what is open in the group at nexte
r and whether there might be a net/cap
server offer could be the right choice
for you right now
what what would you wish for but
what would you do if you
don't save the job now be the job that
the next donata hop starts what about
the 23 top priorities what
do I have to do  or tackle or
first of all who ruled that out because
i would never strive for something like that and do
n't want to do it yet because that's just
that's a lot too it's a lot about
marketing and it's a lot about
not in football the only thing that got me into
this  football i do the whole
theater troops in football only for
saturday 15 and 30 in bielefeld that's
honestly the only date
these woc are  hey
since tuesday not quite as happy as
before but that will come again by then of
course that is of course
not in fact you don't know personally
but
that being there is
not judged by how many points the
german team in the champions
league well and at the end of the day of
course also how she
gets her organizations under control what she
conjures up for the league as a whole in terms of strategic possibilities what she
does for television contracts what she
also wants to give the bundesliga from the
administration for a business card
that is one  Highly
operational task in the official area that
I’m no longer interested in because
I have other people who can do that who can
follow that. I’m
skeptical about
who can do it. No. That’s a different task
such an
organization
in this area would clearly not
only give me empathy dri  n but i think
that the league made a very
good decision and
you just have to let them
do their thing that's not a question i'm always of the opinion
that you have to strengthen the operational level
at the league and just
let them do their thing now has big ones  footsteps
pass through christian seifert but
christian seifert doesn't have the footprints where he came to
her either
they have the end of something power he
'll get soon i don't know but it's
with the pentagon i'm in
regular contact we've been in regular contact
since  half a year dozen
we are now also because i
thought after he had done the work for so many years
to graduate must also be able to
use it and but we do
n't know and if you wanted to tell me
i would say all the best for
you  because then I'm also out of the
raffle against those who squeezed it out
after that, so that's
always fitter and nobody says no
christian seifert of course it was
christian seiffert can work for any bundesliga
club but the top positions
are here and i think based on
the vita he has now after his
career there would not be more for it
below vom seehof is they ca
n’t win yet that’s also clear  yes
back to football is 15 30
but still they friendly yes also
because berliners play with holland and so
now in dortmund but nevertheless that
is somehow probably
not sustainable to keep here
in the long run that is i have to accept
that that is everyone  sure they will go
you can't fight it you
have to accept it in such a way that you say
well like that is already
written everywhere the question is only where
and for how much but actually that they
go when it's
clear well the basic problem is it
more and more in football it is allowed that
states buy themselves and
if we do
n't in any  your way then develop against the
model then it will be difficult
there will always be 45 above all things
that are then so strong that at the
end of the day you can't become me
unless you try to convince the player
but eventually you lose
him but eventually  if you lose every
player what has to do there is also moderate support
and somewhere
the renewal process has to be
permanent that's what I call this
risk model that will have to
do we always
have to heave such a big chunk of rock upwards and when
it does  upstairs the weather is down again
because at some point your best
players were sold again it started all over again
developing a
top European team is
difficult if you don’t manage to keep
the team together at
the level we aren’t but to be
honest that was also before
17 years ago when i started
not the task i was given h  at
i think about it a lot i also look at
what we can
do we can do a lot but to
believe that we can now keep up with abu
dhabi or saudi arabia
then you have to be honest we have
that believes has a bird unless
he  find some model and we
need at the end of the day we need at
some point in germany a national
effort from all the big german companies to counteract this
if we
don’t have that then it will also happen for
bayern munich at some point thinks okay
but that also means for his country for
his
that  is a very special figure because
he is so good from the market because he is
again flat more power than everyone
else actually now from what you
predicted career what
kind of quota he has also how many
points can you get in the end
I'll do another capital increase for you
and say with up to three years you'll do it
here and we'll go as
if you support then of course you
also need
hygiene in the dressing room that means if
you believe now if you go inside for hella
nohl and all the other
players stay the way they are
that's not it that's also then i think that
you're over  the qualities in question
for the people are also
completely on the wrong
level so it's also been a long time since quarterback also
sees around 25 million and
some type of guy has to give them
backs and get them like mr
1000 marks the usa
work the whole transfer market was also
structured differently  it's where it's a completely different
system but again i do
n't want a watch if the price is that
there's no relegation and
no promotion anymore and that all
clubs are franchise companies then
the price for me is to
keep a player  want after before what
would you do if someone
said now man here come 500
million i guess  dortmund's
decree occurs special effect where would you
invest that would you yes in things
yes then we would of course look at
500 million that's a sum then
we would of course advance into other
categories the question is what
does he ask for the 500 million are
there we come when  that simply
wants to free up conditions if we can
make something out of it then you
can now like newcastle what would
you do now newcastle this now in
19th place there may soon
be even more than 500
million they have to sort of get out of
a
small  the english club now want to
make number one who
see best what they are doing i honestly don’t give a
[ __ ] i know
what we are trying to counteract, of course,
by driving for the
next few months
within the ece and also in
the voi of course  try to do
that as much as possible so that the
big madness doesn't happen  n that
we simply
try to regulate the financial fair play more consistently
that is a very difficult fight
but I don't know if we will
win either I'm skeptical but we
lead it that's our way and because
as long as we are still reasonably
stable false fair play  it was a bit
more difficult for the saudis in newcastle
within three years
to be promoted to the top of the world, even
those used for a relatively long time at the time
and
but in the end england gets it despite
are no longer a starter it is
also more of a problem then in the
premier league because if you're
one of the big players at some point
and you can do whatever you want
then that's of course that
was the approach of the super league and if
i hear now they want to
open up and that's the way it is  well and good but they
will then say we open up was
but the premier league there are seven
or eight starting places that again a  Everyone is
happy but that's exactly what
we don't want if it stays with a lot of people
then one will fly soon
now we have the two manchester clubs
have liverpool and chelsea in the
next youth
sometime then one of the four can
say adiós  and then we'll wait and see
how it goes then it's no
coincidence that suddenly
18 out of 20 Premier League clubs now they
would suddenly be audible for for for for Saudi Arabia
and as the same and
you just have to wait and see at
some point it will be  such a system is also
convinced that it is right
is actually the digitization that
you see everywhere in society
economy also for the bundesliga
for borussia dortmund in the end net
positive or negative
yes it doesn’t work a micro-
economic consideration
only make something positive  Does the positive
development benefit you, then that
may be even more positive for other clubs,
but that  you have to face the topic,
it's very clear that
we're currently investing millions in
digitization because of course we
also have a whole lot of projects where
we're trying to use the
principles of ticketing in all
e-commerce, but we're also involved in a
very interesting project  sitting here with
adesso as well as in dortmund
wanting to digitize all sport-relevant data
so it's clear that the company
from the company management that we are
increasingly relying on digitization that
's clear that all the big ones are doing it you
end up being like that if you look now
the possibilities for players to build up
fendt themselves via social platforms are also seen as a club owner or boss, i
would be worried
that suddenly
people no longer follow a club so much as
we have in the player and for the tendency  yes no
I because we already have that you have to
yes if  if you drive through constantly today
and then look a little to the right
100 then you see the
usual bayern and bvb jerseys because
all children in the republic
nationwide in the best certainly more
bvb but in the south certainly a lot
more bayern but then of course you see
jerseys by ronaldo by messi are posh
and they
have a club jersey of water
is paris or manchester united
but at the end of the day it's
related to the player it didn't
used to be 20 30 years ago didn't have a child
here  jersey worn by a player
because i am from germany that
has simply shifted that is completely
clear that is that but that also speaks
completely against the thesis that you can
keep both players in the long term
if they only
market themselves and if at some point more
about it  spoken as before
as how fast are still then
football has finally lost so but
such a tr  ansfer to make a
big rating transfer like he
did before that wouldn't
happen he what did that bring to schalke in the
end
yeah that's honestly the question what's
the point if you then get a player again at the
end of his career then
believe  you that you two years of
radiance then the player is
gone at some point with his career ended
or goes or what for himself in ten
years everyone still wants to
follow raul yes that’s my mum
he was nice for a short time played in the
bundesliga back then  clear but
it's not a model but we always want to
redeem the case are jersey today that
then exceed everything that now
menudo have now gotten ronaldo alone with
the jersey read out by ronaldo jersey
that's already turning everything is found then
it's just more i don't think
anyone  he seriously believes that with the
refinancing of the
total expenditure
with what refinanced part, of course
, then that  s this is never the
best example, but that will
now happen in humans you have
also seen at juventus turin there was
also told because if the now and so
on the train but in the end happy that
it went on that's almost
that was terrible  that a player like
cristiano ronaldo, who for me is
probably the
greatest defensive player the world has ever
produced, but he is handed out on a
silver platter and
manchester united certainly
didn't do it to sell anything,
but at manchester united i think
plays  also a role of course
then the 82 or how many
million followers also plays a role and that
is of course an argument but at
the end of the day you also have to look at it to see
if it matters in the end the
most important thing for me is still the
sporty one  competition i know that this
is no longer the most important thing for everyone
but we should do that in
germany  nd at least preserved how
does it always sound to you
to find the people because that's the
core competency of dortmund for a
few years
these hollands and berlin helms and
before that the mbs and whatever they're all called
that's what you have in life
keeps time after the club so there was klopp
with his special effects and as a person
and then there was this amazing
gauting success if you think it was almost the
same
the club time was the same way
we discovered the top people in
europe back then lewandowski and kagawa
but  it got rid of even in the
club time
that didn't like anything but how does it work
so what is that were you
structurally obvious they
are we have now
obviously there
unique selling point almost
unique selling point because of course
through the career of these players
you can see that the highly talented make
the breakthrough the fastest with
us and  that is of course a resounding argument for
the players for the parents of the players
as well as for the consultants i just talked
to the guys from
ajax they all had games all the players who
now play for us from the younger
good ones they also had us  So
why do everyone think that we're the only
ones to discover that's long gone we
'll get them but because in comparison then
they say then the Bundesliga
obviously has a lot more
punishment radiance attention the
berliner comes next to us and the trainer comes to us
but to believe that ajax him  not also
on the screen is clear but
we do indeed have an advantage that we have
shown that such a player and that
we don’t have any inhibitions
then letting 17-year-olds also
play was the greatest
management achievement in recent months den
heiland  well say
that's not a management feat that's
easy
if you can any player in the world
or  almost everyone gets if you if
you take the offer but a
management
performance in that respect it was certainly so that our offer to
erling was certainly not the best
I think that the manchester united
offer is certainly better but it was
the management performance, if anything,
from rola to recognize that  he is in the
best of hands with us and that and
we have that if you
want to call it a management achievement that
we have created the conditions for over ten years that
it is recognized everywhere in europe today
that is certainly the case and i
am always amazed that  in
germany we currently have the
problem that we only get our faces in the face all day
long at bayern munich it's
just hard to reach at the moment it's
typically german in europe no matter where i
am in europe bvb has a much
higher status and a much
higher one  look at than in germany where
the tabloid media are working their way through
us  because they unloaded all their frustration
that the whole of bayern munich has become champion nine times
on us alone
and abroad the bvb has a
reputation like donnerhall and that's an enormous
discrepancy the bucket hits
again only we are not
completely stupid just as long as bayern
munich
can pay twice as much in salary as borussia dortmund
it will always be difficult the
bayerns have to accommodate us how is it done
eleven or twelve if they
don’t accommodate us but
then you then you just come to the
the the discrepancy in this  difference
that's
140 150 million you can
read that from any balance sheet that you have to
calculate even world-class players how
much the sea is but in the end there
should be more than thirty forty good
players I give my Bayern
can only have 20 pieces in the  have cadres and
then the next 20 years
shouldn't actually be so much worse
that the m  it doesn't have to be that much
worse if you if
your opponent brings a five to ten percent
higher quality on the
pitch then you can hardly be caught at this level it
's just
that it has something to do with consistency it has something to do with it
to do with me
bayern has indeed managed
to have an exceptional team for
years now we have managed to have a very,
very good team for years we are
always there it is pretended
that they are there every year now  being
marched to the title quite easily we
were two years ago at the end two
points behind him should have even
done that in the yes well it's
not like we didn't have a
championship fight if
you then somehow
read some old-timers there in some
newspaper commentaries then have  you got
the feeling that we haven't had a championship fight here for ten years,
even in
the year after we came so
close  in april the situation
that bayern came down it was a
ghost game data
i think four points ahead of us and if
we had won because it had been
one but unfortunately god's individual
lost indicated flicks from kimi and
we try everything that is possible but
it is  even if you drive the car that
only half of the bestsellers
are supposed to drive permanently, then that's it, you have
to hope for the driving mistakes of the other person,
otherwise it's tight and
there's no alternative to what
bavaria has built up over 50 years, we ca
n't do that  ten years in north rhine-
westphalia where the structures are or
worse than in bavaria
we can't get it is that bayern in
that case you too now with uli
hoeness he's really the
most successful german sports manager be
different is for me is
clearly can  it was absolutely
lying around openly for me the last as chairman of the
board is
i think 20 years  se that was the
most successful of bayern munich and
that is a public that
maybe you think we see but
i as someone who
can look at it from the inside abt had the utmost
respect because i don't know anyone who is more
analytical in this business who has
such a clear view  also on the on
the on the football has
such an excellent international network
so his performance was
exceptional in the last 20 years
the performance of hoeneß
should not be diminished at all his
strongest phase was i superstition before that
how strong is the lack of
Schalke is too lamented about the mistake they
made, which still has to be corrected.
He will rise again
. That can't be prevented. What has an
inner strength because of the fact that
they have a very strong tradition,
that they are always
passed on to families  so much
failure can not have
that not in one part de  r genetics are
passed on to the family
schalke will be promoted again i
think even this year
but promotion is one thing but
if you are relegated
you lose so much substance that it will be
very difficult to get back
up that
it can take longer than  five to
ten years until they can be used properly again
at all, if at all,
schalke naturally has a lot of
negative influencing factors as well, so
the doubles can’t
necessarily be compared to hamburg or munich,
but to
be honest, gelsenkirchen is
economically much more difficult than it
is than dortmund and  of course we
each have
pole position in north rhine-westphalia so if we start over
the last ten years or
how many we have won four titles
from villages 12 and
then the title from 17 and then add that
now  we four titles
probably those were simply the only four
titles  which were awarded in North Rhine-Westphalia
within ten years,
so that means bvb has of course grazed quite a bit with
sponsorship and everywhere in North Rhine-Westphalia,
but there is not that much there
either  it is the case in
bavaria but in hamburg, for
example, a similar situation will arise in the
next few years, your assessment will come
again hamburg of course has the
problem that you are now playing for the fourth year
in the second division is
a drama for me because we definitely have it
for me  the most beautiful german
city and i love hamburg and
i looked forward to it every year when
we played there because it's just
fantastic and that's a
special tragedy that's hard
to understand even for outsiders
but the longer you're in the second division
, the more difficult it is  if it's the car
, as a hamburger you have to adjust yourself somehow
to five to ten years
w  If at all they
get back up there yes and above all
that is yes the problem is yes
if you were of course very
successful before then you of
course have the problem that then there
are an
incredible number of people sitting in the stands of such clubs and they all say yes
we  sooner if i hear that if
i hear it will belong i have
already told my people i
will no longer be responsible at some point
we will only tie in the stands let's say
sooner then he will shoot me right
away but of course there are plenty of them
and that can be done  also a problem that's not a
problem
and they were very successful in a few weeks
and that will of course
be in such a big city and
a media city but in bulva city
it will of course be then you
always have people yes we used to
we didn't have it at all  moved we won with
seven men
and you
really have to here where there is dortmund the
environment in d  ortmund lied and the
people in westphalia
don't praise it that much so
you have to say that now you can say we
're the successful ones too we've been the
whole year but this i'll name
in the pilot's license mentalities because
they're pronounced here and  this also helps
here
our colleagues from
vodafone have
a new offer for business customers ready for the release of the iphone 13
if, for
example, you use the vodafone red business prime
tariff, i.e. the optimal tariff
for business customers, let me say
the tariff is also 5g-capable
and then you can now do the following
and trade in your old smartphone
at vodafone, the high beam will no
longer be there, but for the entire company
and the entire company, upgrade the entire fleet
to the new, more powerful
iphone 13 and, of course, benefit even more
from the vodafone business
premium  tariff but has all kinds of
benefits of course if you
video conferencing on the go makes
higher quality, of course, you also benefit
from the simplicity of ios 5 10
so all this will now the smartphones
of colleagues colleagues trade in
at vodafone there is the brisk upgrade
a suitable tariff and what my
cell phone all info vodafone.de fleets  upgrade
look a lot at what is happening in the usa
and sport
in the marketing of the clubs yes
i watch all
us sport myself of course i hardly ever watch it
because half of the sport i don't
understand the rules and
the other is me  to be honest it
's not my type of sport it's
too pompous for me too much of a show
around it when i sometimes see the players
that people only come after 35
minutes and then change again 170
during the break it's the busiest
and the whole model  I don't
like the way it works how is
marketing technically run so that of
course you are interested but
are super  he bowl-like serve
and trying to do something is
probably one of the very few
people who have never seen a super
well and it will
stay that way but of course I honestly
know that it fascinates a lot of people
that's okay that none at all
but the question is just another one
I'm a bit more
consciously positioned but of course I
don't recognize any other super bowl people
something that is all over the world
I've just never been
interested in the game I have to be honest I have to
say that I'm when  then more like the
ice hockey fan because that's what I'll watch
up function because the
sport the sport fascinates me
but with american football and baseball
and should then I've always been strangers
that I don't see him in the
row although that's probably a
knowledge  has to do with the fact that i have to watch so many
football games i do
n't even know what to watch but i want to go to
this one  zen innovations even now
when, for example, chelsea also starts
to market a training jersey
and things like that look at yourself or
are there people celebrating we also
have to have a point has been
reached again where i say
economy isn’t everything, for example
the fact that we only play in black and
yellow doesn't make it a luxury either no one can afford it
anymore because we just do it that
way because it's just our
DNA and not because some of the jerseys
of some clubs can be seen then then
I'll go nuts then, well, then
but when borussia dortmund wears their
colors i will
no longer enter the stadium
watching them watch how their grandchildren consume football i.e. what
platform do you know for them would they
watch football while
my grandchildren who i don’t have yes
ok me  of course what i
am interested in i am yes i have
the great advantage that i quantify my grounding
in that  I was 27 years
ago from Rosas
Heiligenhaus
and I go there from time to time
and then I spoke to many
spokespersons with the youth players
and I like that
multitasking is a big problem
that today
many younger players are no longer ready
to be able to play for 90 minutes
then of course you also have to
incorporate that into a marketing
strategy that’s also already happening in the dfl of this highlight reporting
and son and lives even if I’m
mostly sanctuary what doesn’t happen
often to me but it does happen
times before if not more then and students
so I for is students say cdu and
watch games then
the parents all scream around because
every 3 minutes also do it in the iphone
and you have to face it was a
club so the people who are 90
minutes  look at the game quite consistently without letting yourself be
distracted
en also show up from time to time to
install such things or
myself I will I
assume that I will not post but he
assume that I am represented
but not under my name
is still a big discussion a big
discussion for us too  I do
n't do it anymore, of course,
in the sponsoring area
there are others who say you
just have to do it because a few people
would follow in the end and
then I also have a two
people
[music]
who I should take
seriously and talk about it and say let
it be worthy in your situation
because we know you and in the end
you also have a lot of Maoism in you and
you also look at what they then
write as comments and that brings
it then not so if i
imagine i would now go into the valley
under my name and where is that from the
game something from the region buyer
arena and then on  in the end you get
about 30,000 comments,
29,800 of which are you are the biggest failure on
the planet because that led to the
overall assessment
not doing it okay but i follow i
follow some people who know that
then also to get some impressions
also the player probably
to watch what these games that's me
for me we poach our
social media but of course i'm
also interested in other areas
culture sports
an entertainment and that's
not so that i actively
participate there ok ok but  it's
still natural i think in my children
but if you
ask yourself now how do young people
consume football it's different and sometimes
you don't even know where
it used to be so you knew that's where
the athletes are coming from  the gym comes
and then there was a run but
meanwhile it's been like that forever most of them
don't come to me d  a the television that
is very clear that war with that will
then happen via ipad and iphone and via
laptop and what do I know what that is
already clear and that has simply
shifted and i think it should
be like that for example from my point of view  whether to
do but i think that the short
reporting is more cultivated
than the live games and i do
n't know but i have the feeling that
whenever i'm younger and the
speakers usually don't just have the highlights
you don't have to do much
even thinking about changing the rules of the game in
certain areas to
say that in this overall
predatory competition of the sports of
the other offers and say
short-term attention
spans and say well we always do
with our 45 minutes and then that in the
long run is if he’s totally against because  i
say the fascination of football also
comes from the fact that you do
n't keep changing the rules on a sunday and things
have to be easy  oh stay there and three times 30
minutes so that you have longer commercial
breaks and so the character of the
game would be completely changed and a game
that is still very clearly and far ahead of
everything else the number one in the
world does not have too much pressure to change in my opinion
like  how did your special
friendship with the renault come about oh my goodness
and the free coincidence well
we played the leads
against greuther fürth in the bundesliga years ago
and to my complete
surprise it was suddenly there we were
playing four days later or one
week later no idea against real
madrid that was 12 13 went to the final
and
the game was somewhere is then because we
are already waiting after 30 minutes i think
that a dog is in the lead and good and
then we sat close
we chatted a bit  and you
somehow have that
people who have completely
installed football have noticed
that  s of each other that's how I got to know one time in
the 90s so
I just hope to get to know union
and then something will come of it that's
gone but do it because here I
couldn't even introduced myself to
doubts not even as if
namely kant  But I'm pretty sure
that it wasn't like that. I didn't know that
after the first loss
here, I then noticed that
they lost twice and
then that's the no, but
we just found a personal
connection that in the design plan  and
then watched my games
and then not together but
we talked a bit afterwards
yes and
we just talked that was
ten years ago or something and then
we just got along over the years
especially the times when he didn't have a
club you just
met like that my daughter was
studying in oxford when i d  he then visited
then i met him in
london or something like that when you
eat together we also
talked about very private things and so that's out of the sea is
yes that's free now there's one on the
job and one private the private one is
world class he is  world class and he
confirms that but also everyone who
knows him really well the field the tip and
now of course it's like now in
these phases we write but
we don't see each other regularly but
meanwhile it would ever go with doping
well let's put it that way  i don't think
that he was
ever really seriously interested in germany because
he
also discusses [music] with me when I do things like that
but he sees a
huge language problem from time to time he
actually speaks every language except german
and he says german is for me
too  the language is completely different from
the others i have of course
portuguese spanish english it was clear
we could go to italy  notice there
is also a lot of similarity and
france is a lot of similarity
but saying german sounds like
russian to me and hard to learn
and
i think that high seas
now
he still loves the premier league
that's clear but more because italy very much
successful and that is now
a project also a strong investor
now it's clear well well
i don't think he
would change a bundesliga again
what do you think the dfb file
is up the network is talking
about it i still have it in some
way  to get involved because something
is going on I say it's difficult let's
say it's certainly difficult but
meanwhile you have to say we're no
longer playing for the DFB it's also
for the entire structure behind it as
well as for the individual club it feels like it's
already suffering more  than just the
specific people in the dfb and they say
that it's an internal problem, that's
pretty clear now, a little bit  n
next, yes, we need
a management structure in German
football that also enjoys a certain level of
public and social acceptance
, that means there must be
people who also
have an impact on society, that's the most important thing, of course
, the most important thing for the Germans is the
national team  that's clear, but for
football in these difficult times,
especially in the kroner
situation, i often missed the fact that there were
people who were also there from time to time,
a little bit maybe they
just moved
the editors at the dfb, keep to yourself  was
busy myself and of course everyone was
so damaged because it didn't get
through, but ideally things
will change again, that
we can regain our position and
there are an incredible number of positive
things when I see how courageously
the clubs use them  the dfb the topic
who has them so lasting and also so
credible
concerned with the topic of racism like we do in football because
integration, for example, is
something that would be done by
integration work as football
clubs, amateur clubs in all areas
i have never experienced that when the
youth team plays together from
seven nations that there is
a lot of racism  problem
would have existed but that is exactly this
integrative power
that football can offer we would have made that
much clearer even if this one where
everyone was just discussing that in
the corona period football was
total nonsense but football is over
privileged and everything  nonsense
but no one objected and
we have to go back there the
national team is one issue
i see us on the right track and
but the delta association itself
has to shine with the oscar there
has to be its political
function again  social function that
perceive patterns and must not
more steer are in small
wars for that if you look at who his
person could be in germany it
doesn't matter from which office
but rather sonja
radiates so many there are not so many
in the district 1 567 people
would  they also belong, for example, to
the have so far for me so the
president of the dfb is completely
out of the question for me now today no always
out of the question because the
president of the dfb would mean that borussia dortmund would have to
step up
in everyone no matter in which function i
would then have to file it and that will happen
never happen because my life
is something in this area offer from and
and no association and no right if I
don't want to change anyone's club I would
never switch to the association if I
had to give up my job at bvb
so that's out of the question
but I already have  once said i
know it comes down to it when
at some point German professional football  the
opinion is that he could use me in some
way and there is a vacancy it's
obviously
right there now then i wouldn't
refuse but definitely not as a
dfb president i've been
on the dfl side not only since he did because i'm also there for it
not then borussia dortmund
would have to stop and the
crucial thing is that the amateurs
and they don't have to tell anyone about
amateur football because as i said
if you've been leading the club for 27 years then
you already know your way around i've never had that in any association in
the 27 years at the cape
it's clear but i don't
think there are that many people in the dfb,
also in the state associations and state
presidencies or how that then
ran an amateur club for over 27 years so it has to be dealt
with
at least now if i
'm against in the dfl at some point  should take office
that's certainly a big advantage
for me - from which no one tells
how it works in amateur football and how
it is  it looks like i can do that quite well,
but you still have the right
to propose the DFB president
and to believe that now that
you can't propose a candidate
to the amateurs then maybe
expect that he now by virtue of
his personality from day one
we developed the giants straight away,
some people also develop them in office
and you just have to bet on it
that maybe
at some point the DFB will also have people
who then also use this opportunity, the
last ones just didn't use
it, you have to admit that self-critically
but  for professional football it is
basically we have a third of the
votes on the federal parliament that
means i had to
arrange it with the dfb too that clearly
how long can you generally do a job like that
at dortmund so my little one be a member for
life and maybe
also be active on behalf but now
in the management responsibility
the man  now you probably think about it
from time to time
but how is it going then one day it was
again i'll do it
again i have the strength to do it too
yes that's not that it's not
infinite that's very clear but
this association  has more to offer
than just the position of the case in the
management and insofar as i know
for me only 1 percent and will support me
until the last day i will
accompany borussia dortmund or
not borussia dortmund that is not a question but
that is of course
that  25 my plan runs until 23
and i'll get to the end of it at some point
25 also if i'm entitled to a pension then
also
statutory pension insurance you're
then of course
yes that's for that i'm
also German and the German is
always a certain need for
security  and
then it's certainly but then
you have to think about it carefully, but I
'll be damned and at some point
say d  ann and then it's definitely
over from that moment on you
still have half of the breakthrough and but
i know that it's finally
here you get a sense of how
bayern are making their
offspring rules we just talked about rummenigge and like
them  whole generation almost now yes
currently it seems to manage
to hand over the recipe at all levels and that
seems to work now a little
let's wait and see and that can say that
can't be
the case they were made at least
silently that's good and
now you have to  give oliver kahn and then his comrades-in-arms the opportunity to prove
that
you have to work for more than 45 years
that's not a problem eight weeks later
that has nothing to do with the current
bundesliga table
because the team
is still there the way it is  run on strong under the
aegis of von kalle rummenigge
has the tools for that
no question but the rest of the must  s the
next few years will prove the
basic prerequisite for the top in munich
is one of the most exciting tasks of
all there is already clear but cold
then also calwer 66 is exactly the
age I then 25 also hair and following in the
same footsteps is
already admission or
you have to  now
also slowly see who that could not
be something like that here in dortmund, yes,
don't worry
, we would not
address that in a podcast or in the media,
but we will and if that
should happen at some point, it still
is  not that far also there are
still four years of contract that's still a
long time
and you can't
look four years in advance because you have to come to
yourselves in four years the
world of football will change completely
and but we'll borussia
dortmund will be something  it doesn't matter what
I
'm sure is my most important tasks if that
should happen at some point then there
people
like that p  present who have the overall trust
of the club, but that you can
create what you
can without making a
sound  then we got
relatively quietly with the
chinese again great
competence where the whole of germany is still
raging about whether that can say
that he then issues the cones for a
rose or not we
just solved it so we can and that's where
i see it  the whole thing is good and
a championship is still possible by 2025
i should be the goal but i have
already been like that then we should be very
happy the southern star we have to do
a little bit however a
driving error times thank you very much for the
conversation
thank you
for the decision of  reference to our
in-house academy there is a
wide variety of courses to choose from  on
november 5th we start again
, e-mail marketing fundamentals with
our colleagues from fink 3, i.e. from the
agency, who support us in
transferring optimal knowledge to
you, it is about topics such as
distribution list management data management
automation tracking reporting
optimization  everything to do with the
e-mail marketing channel, of course, a mostly very
underestimated channel with real power
behind it, it starts on 15 november
for listeners to the podcast, there is a
ten percent discount code with the
discount code mr podcast when
you register at
www.duh.de  enter it and then it runs
automatically the whole thing then runs for
ten weeks by the way now i have to
learn per week as with all our
courses the technically good work there are no dime experts so
there is no
certificate with reebok has no schau
billion
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at  Mr